pourquoi Francisco Benitez prend-il le
risque d'inviter Maria Teresa chez lui
alors que sa femme et sa fille partis
pour une petite escapade peuvent revenir
à tout
instant s'il a pris la décision de faire
venir sa maîtresse chez lui cette
nuit-là une nuit toute entière c'est
qu'il savait pertinemment qu'elle ne
risquait pas de
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
revenir
bonjour à tout le monde je
suis le 5 at 2013 la France entière
découvre le témoignage de ce père de
famille il s'appelle
franciscoitez il a 5 ans et c'est un
légionnaire
plus
[Musique]
des des soupçons qui pèsent sur lui
depuis la disparition de sa femme et de
sa fille
Alison 19 ans elle rêvait de devenir
Miss France et elle s'est volatilisé
[Musique]
elle était sur le point d'être élu Miss
Roussillon
elle pensait vraiment qu'elle pourrait
aller à Miss France ça a
été un
choc je la laisse à ce rond-po là mais
je ne sa sais pas avec qui elle parle
quand on voit qui qu' retrouve du sang
on se dit mais
voilà on a retrouvé de l'ADN il s'est
passé quelque
[Musique]
chose nous sommes le samedi 15 juillet
2013 sur la plage du Canet à une
vingtaine de kilomètres de
Perpignan il est
18h c'est ici que les 12 candidates à de
Miss Roussillon on rendez-vous pour une
partie de Beach
[Musique]
volet seulement au moment de commencer
la partie Cindy la responsable du
concours s'aperçoit qu'une des jeunes
filles manque à l'appel et là je me dis
ah oui effectivement Alison Alison n'est
pas là c'est pas possible la jeune fille
en question c'est Alison Benitez elle a
19 ans et son absence a quelque chose
d'inquiétant car c'est la candidate
peut-être la plus motivée du groupe
elle pensait vraiment queelle pourrait
gagner Miss et qu'elle pourrait aller à
Miss France av même arrêté de travailler
apparemment quelques temps plus de 4
mois je crois parce travaill dans un
salon de coiffure et justement pour
s'investir pleinement dans dans ce
concours de beauté alors pourquoi Alison
n'est pas là Cindy tente aussitôt de la
joindre par téléphone en
20 c'est c'est automatiquement le
répondeur il y a pas de il y a pas de
sonnerie donc là je m'inquiète je me dis
quand même c'est
bizarre un tel silence cela n'est
vraiment pas dans les habitudes de la
jeune fille c'était celle qui m'envoyé
le plus de messages en tout cas même
quand elle avait décidé de de faire une
soirée entre entre amis où aller en
boîte de nuit elle me demandait si elle
avait la possibilité de le faire si ça
craignait pas jusque tard dans la nuit
Cindy essera par tous les Mo
de
joindreon y compris via les réseaux
sociaux mais sa page Facebook et son
compte Twitter sont au point mort et
cela ne ressemble vraiment pas à la
jeune
fille ouion elle était très actif sur
les réseaux sociaux et son téléphone et
tout ça tout le temps tout le temps qu'
a pas un jour où elle y allait pas de
pas l'avoir connecté ça aussi c'est
quelque chose de pas normal où est passé
Alison pourquoi a-t-elle coupé son
téléphone du jour au
lendemain le 17 juillet 2013 soit 2
jours après sa disparition Alexandre un
ami d'Allison décide de se rendre chez
la jeune
fille c'est dans ce quartier populaire
de
Perpignan dans cet appartement qu'Alison
vit avec son père et sa mère quand il
arrive le jeune homme est très inquiet
je sonne une fois et personne me répond
mais j'ai entendu les chien boyés il y
avait la fenêtre ouverte de la cuisine
donc j'ai dit bon ben je je réessaye
c'est qu'il doit y avoir quelqu'un
finalement au bout de quelques minutes
c'est Francisco Benitez le père de la
jeune fille qui sort sur le balcon je
lui demande si Alisson est là que ça
fait de jours qu'on l'a pas vu et il me
répond al ah Alisson va bien elle est
partie avec sa mère à Toulouse elles ont
coupé les téléphones à ce moment-là
Alexandre n'a aucune raison de mettre en
doute la parole du père d'Allison et
pour cause Francisco Benitez est un vrai
papa pou la première fois que j'ai vu
monsieur Benitez c'était pour l'élection
Miss Perpignan B Perpignan et il était
venu voir Alisson il était très on
aurait dit qu'il avait vu la Vierge on
va dire il arrêtait pas de faire des
photos de très très fier de sa fille son
père je le voyais comme quelqu'un de
très attentif très gentil il
était moi il m'a donné une impression
que il donnerait tout pour sa
fille pour tous les proches de la
famille d'Allison cet escapade à
Toulouse de la mère et de la fille est
plausible seulement il y a une personne
qui n'y croit pas une seule seconde
c'est Cindy la responsable du concours
pour elle Alison ne serait jamais parti
sur un coup de tête je le dis d'ailleurs
à Alexandre je dis non c'est impossible
elle est pas à Toulouse elle est pas à
Toulouse elle me l'aurait dit on est à
un mois de l'élection où c'est là où
j'ai le plus besoin de mes candidates
que c'est là où il y a le plus
d'activités et surtout Alisson qui est
la plus
motivée de plus en plus inquiet les amis
d'Allison décide de prendre les choses
en
main alors le 25 juillet soit 11 jours
après la disparition de la jeune fille
son ami Alexandre accompagné de F une
autre candidate à l'élection de Miss
Roussillon se rendent au commissariat de
Perpignan pour alerter la
policeous ça nès bizarre même sil nous
écoute pas on commence à raconter
l'histoire au mec de l'accueil qui
devait s'en peut-être la preuve
que non vu que 2 minutes après on était
quand même reçu dans les bureaux on a
été convaincant seulement dès le début
et et puis on éétait pas là pour
inventer on voyait bien sur nos visages
que on s'inquiétait réellement
à la grande surprise des deux jeunes
gens c'est donc le commissaire
divisionnaire en personne qui les reçoit
dans son bureau face au fonctionnaire de
police Sophie l'autre candidate va
raconter dans les moindres détails
l'emploi du temps d'Allison la veille de
sa disparition soit le 14 juillet
2013 ce matin-là sophie n'a rien noté
d'anormal le Comité Miss Roussillon
avait organisé une partie de jet ski
pour les futures miss et à 10h Alison
était bien au rendez-vous comme on peut
le voir sur ses photos à ce momentlà au
dire de ses amis la jeune fille était
légère et
insouciante c'était vraiment c'était
fire sur fourire même à 11h et dem elle
voulait tellement continuer qu'on soit
toutes ensemble elle a dit ça vous
dirait de ça vous plairait bien d'aller
au
restaurant seulement au cours du
déjeuner l'humeur et le comportement
d'Allison vont on brusquement changé
pour ses amis quelque chose la chagrine
il tente d'en savoir plus mais la jeune
fille est rivée à son portable et quand
on lui pose des questions c'était oui
non mais il y avait pas de dialogue on
l'a sentait vachement prise par son
téléphone et cetera donc et on savait
que elle discutait avec son père puis
qu'elle nous l'a dit nul ne connaît la
teneur des échanges entre Alison et son
père mais toujours est-il qu'au cours de
ce déjeuner la jeune fille semble de
plus en plus perturbé
[Musique]
du repas arrive on décide d'aller manger
une glace au glacier du coin et du coup
elle nous dit je je commence à être
fatiguée je vais partir elle nous dit
que son père arrive donc moi je devais
quitter je devais aussi les quitter donc
on décide de de marcher en direction de
l'endroit où il avait donné rendez-vous
à son père c'est ici que John verra la
jeune fille pour la dernière fois je la
laisse à ce rond-point là mais je ne
sais pas avec qui elle part je ne sais
pas avec qui elle part je je ne regarde
pas avec qui elle va monter dans la dans
quelle voiture elle
[Musique]
monte le lendemain le 15 juillet 2013 à
18h la jeune fille ne se présente pas au
Beach volet alors ses amis comprennent
qu'il s'est certainement passé quelque
chose de
[Musique]
grave
les policiers prennent la déposition des
amis d'Allison très au sérieux d'autant
qu'ils ne sont pas les premiers à venir
leur parler de cette
affaire car un homme s'est déjà présenté
au commissariat il y a quelques jours
cet homme n'est autre que Francisco
benénitez le père de la jeune fille il
avait expliqué au policier que son
épouse et sa fille étaient partis à
Toulouse pour une courte escapade mais
aujourd'hui il est inquiet car elles ne
sont pas revenu et elles sont
injoignables il signale simplement la
disparition de sa fille et de sa femme
oralement et il s'en va le père puis les
amis d'adison cette double disparition
commence à être prise très au sérieux
par la
police d'autant que tout le monde se
demande pourquoi la plus motivée des
candidates serait partie en pleine
préparation d'un concours qui lui tenait
tant à
cœur quelques jours plus tard les
policiers décident de réentendre le père
d'Allison un homme de 53 ans adjud en
chef dans la légion et très bien noté
par sa
hiérarchie face aux enquêteurs l'homme
va se montrer très coopératif et
raconter dans les détails la dernière
fois qu'il a vu sa fille c'était le 14
juillet 2013 vers 14h il a récupéré
Alisson sa fille qui était partie
s'occuper de son son concours de Miss
Roussillon qu'il l'a ramené à la maison
le légionnaire précise qu'à leur retour
une violente dispute l'a opposée à son
épouse Marie
José il ajoute que depuis quelques temps
son couple battait de l'elle et
d'ailleurs c'est suite à cet accrochage
que sa femme et Alison auraient décidé
de quitter le domicile familial
elles ont décidé de partir elles ont
quitté le
domicile elles sont parties avec
l'intention d'aller à Toulouse et après
c'est sa déclaration il ne sait pas plus
le 14 juillet en fin de journée les deux
femmes seraient donc parties à pied avec
quelques
affaires selon Francisco benitz Marie
José aurait même informé Lydia sa fille
aînée de son
départ un texto a bien été adressé donc
par par Marie José à à à sa
fille j'ai pris une décision difficile
mais c'est mieux comme ça je pars à
Toulouse avec Alison je vous
aime depuis plus rien 11 jours se sont
écoulés et la mère de famille n'a plus
donné aucune nouvelle son téléphone est
toujours
muet le 25 juillet le parquet ouvre donc
une enquête pour disparition inquiétante
[Musique]
à ce stade deux options se profilent
pour les enquêteurs la piste du départ
volontaire comme l'a déclaré le père de
famille les deux femmes ont peut-être
décidé de couper les ponts et de partir
pour Toulouse mais il y a une deuxième
hypothèse plus inquiétante celle-là la
deuxème possibilité c'est la mauvaise
rencontre parce qu'on sait quand même
que ni l'une ni l'autre ne dispose d'un
permis de conduire ce qui veut dire
qu'elles ont dû pour aller à Toulouse
aller à la gare qui est à 3 km à
pied les enquêteurs cherchent alors des
témoins oculaires si Alison et sa mère
ont marché en direction de la gare où
ont fait du stop peut-être que quelqu'un
les a
vu d'autant que les policiers ont un
atout dans leur recherche le physique
d'Alison il y a pas un type qui ne se
retournait pas sur elle dans la rue donc
forcément si fait 3 km à pied entre son
domicile et la gare forcément si elle a
véritablement fait ce trajet il y a un
témoin qui l'a vu pourtant à chaque fois
les policiers vont se heurter à la même
réponse personne n a vu sortir de son
domicile de leur domicile ni Alison ni
Marie José le fameux dimanche 14 juillet
au
soir pire les caméras de la gare de
perpignant nont jamais enregistré leur
présent sur les
quai si elles avaient été sur le quai
pour prendre le train de Toulouse
forcément on les aurait récupéré sur la
vidéo alors que sont devenus Alison la
jolie prétendante au titre de Miss et sa
mère Marie José les deux femmes semblent
s'être volatilisées et dans les jours
qui vont suivre personne dans leur
entourage n'aura de
nouvelles le mois de juillet 2013 touche
à sa fin et plus la date de l'élection
approche et moins l'ambiance au sein du
concours de beauté est à la fête bien au
contraire on
était toujours à se demander si Alison
allait réapparaître puis elle était la
favorie du concours donc de on était pas
dans un dans le même état d'esprit que
les autres années c'est un peu une un un
gros un gros nuage qui nous qui nous
tombe un peu sur la tête parce que on
sait pas à quoi s'attendre le choc est
profond d'autant que pour les candidates
et ses amis Alison était une jeune fille
sans histoire et qui faisait l'unanimité
autour d'elle Alisson j'ai le souvenir
d'elle d'une fille qui était toujours
souriante toujours jolie attentionnée
par rapport à ses amis et tout ça Alison
c'est aussi une jeune fille choyée et
aimée par ses deux parents Marie José et
Francisco Bénitez un couple dont
l'histoire d'amour ressemble à un compte
de fé
nous sommes dans les années 90 à
Marseille Marie- José vit seule avec ses
quatre enfants la vie est dure elle ne
peut compter que sur son maigre salaire
de serveuse pour assurer le quotidien de
sa
famille alors quand le beau légionnaire
Francisco Benitez entre dans sa vie il
fait figure de Prince
Charmant le mec il arrive dans sa vie il
a pas d'argent il lui donne de l'argent
il fait les courses avec les petits il
les emmène à McDo
tout ça les enfants ma sœur ils avaient
pas connu très vite Marie José et
Francisco s'installent ensemble et 2 ans
plus tard la jeune femme donne naissance
à Alison au dire de tous leurs proches
la famille vit le parfait amour et le
légionnaire apparaît comme un père et un
mari attentionné et aimant à Marie il
lui faisait jamais de mal parce que
Marie me disait qu' lui faisait pas de
mal il était gentil était
serviable
alorsis estil vraiment cet homme idéal
que décrivent ses proches tout le monde
n'est pas de cet
avis c'est le cas de Cindy
l'organisatrice de l'élection d'mise
Roussillon depuis le début elle pense
que le père de famille ne dit pas toute
la vérité concernant l'escapade
toulousaine de sa femme et de sa fille
pour moi déjà je j'annonce que il ment
je ne le connais pas je ne l'ai jamais
vu
mais je ne sais même pas à ce momentl le
métier qu'il fait je sais rien du tout
mais je je sais qu'il ment et la suite
de l'affaire semble lui donner
raison le 30 juillet 2013 soit 15 jours
après la disparition d'Allison Cindy
décide d'alerter la presse elle prend en
contact avec l'un de ses amis
journalistes au quotidien local je dis
bon ben je sais pas si ça se fait mais
est-ce que tu peux mettre une photo
d'elle sur le journal en disant que elle
a disparu là on est le 30 juillet et le
30 juillet donc il nous préviennent en
nous disant est-ce qu'on peut faire
quelque chose nous n'avons pas de
nouvelles de cette jeune fille donc ma
collègue contacte les services de police
et nous diffusons un avis de recherche
le jour même c'est la première fois que
les médias s'emparent de l'affaire et
immédiatement une chose étonne les
journalistes pourquoi Francisco
benénitez le père de famille n'a jamais
pris la peine de les
contacter on en fait d'autres
disparitions souvent on remu les terres
enfin la famille remuci les terres c'est
c'est vrai qu'on est'est pas dans ce
cadre là mais nous ce qui nous fait
bizarre peut-être ce qui peut nous
intriguer c'est que il nous contacte pas
on on n pas eu de contact avec luous
alors Francisco Benitez aurait-il
quelque chose à cacher ce n'est pas
[Musique]
impossible de leur côté les enquêteurs
ont fait de bien inquiétantes
découvertes depuis le 15 juillet les
comptes en banque des deux disparus
n'affichent aucun mouvement d'argent ce
qui inaugure rien de
bon évidemment dans ces conditions là ça
accrédite le caractère inquiétant de
cette disparition et ce n'est pas tout
d'après l'étude de la téléphonie la
dernière émission du portable de Marie
José a accroché une borne dans le
quartier où elle habite à Perpignan le
15 juillet or ce jour-là selon benénitez
son épouse et sa fille devait être à
Toulouse ça veut dire qu'elles n'ont
jamais pris le train en direction de
Toulouse le mystère se trouve peut-être
derrière les fenêtres de l'appartement
familiale le 1er août 2013 la police
judiciaire décide donc de procéder à une
fouille minutieuse du domicile des
bénits vu la situation ils ne peuvent
pas faire l'économie d'une perquisition
au domicile de la famille benénit et
donc ils vont y
aller et une fois sur place lesers on
faire plusieurs découvertes qui laissent
penser qu'un drame s'est joué dans la
maison d'abord dans un tiroir de
l'appartement il tombe sur les
passeports des deux
femmes on sait maintenant qu'elles ne
peuvent pas quitter le territoire
puisque leur passeport est resté à leur
domicile qu'ell n'utilise pas leur moyen
de paiement et qu'elle n'utilise pas
leur téléphone ça commence à faire
beaucoup
l'histoire la découverte des passeports
éveille aussitôt les soupçons des
enquêteurs alors il décide de passer
l'appartement et le garage au luminol un
produit qui révèle la présence de sang
si un drame s'est joué ici il y a
peut-être encore des
[Musique]
traces une source proche de l'enquête
dit qu'il y avait des traces de sang
qu'après le passage du luminol que
luminol aurait révélé des taches de
sang des traces de sang dans l'appart
dans le garage du couple mais aussi
étrange que cela puisse paraître malgré
cette terrible découverte le père d'On
n'est pas
interpellé on peut se poser
raisonblement la question de savoir
pourquoi ils l'ont pas coffré à ce
momentl pourquoi ils l'ont pas au moins
placé en garde à vue pour obtenir des
explications monsieur pourquoi il y a du
sang chez vous est-ce une stratégie les
enquêteurs attendaientil d'avoir plus
d'éléments pour interpeller le père de
famille quoi qu'il en soit 4 jours à
peine après la perquisition de son
domicile Francisco Benitez va prendre
tout le monde de cours et plonger la
France entière dans la
stupéfaction bonjour à tousation RTL une
dernière minute de perpign le cor sans
vie de Francesco benit vient d'être
retrouvé il sagit Mar du père des de
disparus introuva depuis un mois les
détails début ce
journal
le 5 août au petit matin le père
d'Allison est découvert pendu à la
balustrade d'une fenêtre de son
appartement de fonction de la caserne de
Perpignan pour tout le monde c'est la
stupeur ça a
été un choc parce que on se disait
c'était peut-être le seul à savoir où
elles sont vraiment si elles sont
cachées si elles sont parti à l'étranger
plein de cas sont possibles et on se
disait qu'il y avait que lui pour
connaître et qu'il était plus là ce
suicide pose question car les policiers
découvrent qu'avant de mettre fin à ses
jours benénitez a rédigé un ma à
l'intention de son
colonel dans ce message l'homme clame
son innocence et termine par cette
phrase souvenez-vous du bénitz que vous
connaissez chose troublante le
légionnaire ne laisse aucun mot ni à sa
fille ni à sa femme
comment de sa mort il laisse pas
à sa femme et à sa
fille au cas où ou pour le moment où
elle réapparaîtrait elle
reviendrait c'est la prière
interrogation de ceier c'est C si
Benitez n'a laissé aucun mot à sa
famille en revanche il a pris soin de
mettre en scène sa mort au petit matin
le légionire C soigneusement ses
rangers enfile son tray et toutes ces
décorations puis il se voile le visage
avec un foulard noir avant de se pendre
accroché à la balustrade de la
[Musique]
caserne et pour crier son innocence
l'homme va aller plus
loin dans l'après-midi du 5 août
quelques heures après l'annonce du
suicide de Francisco
Benitez une incroyable vidéo est mise en
ligne sur le site d'un grand
hebdomadaire français durant de longues
minutes de monologue le légionnaire en
larme explique qu'il ne supporte pas
l'absence d'adison et encore moins les
soupçons qui pèent sur lui le plus pour
nous ça été de lire des choses que les
gens monter et dit sans savoir qu'est-ce
qui passe dans la vie privée des gens
nous somm famille comme toutre famille
avec des ha
Desbat Francisco Benitez a tout planifié
cette vidéo avait été enregistrée 2
jours avant son suicide et il l'avait
remise à une journaliste qui le
sollicitait pour une
interview là elle voit un homme
totalement effondré parfois en larme
parfois
tremblotant entretien se déroule dans la
voiture de bénitess il ne lui dira rien
de de de de particulier si ce n'est
qu'il va lui remettre cette fameuse
vidéo à peine diffusée sur le site du
journal la vidéo se met à circuler en
boucle sur Internet et sur toutes les
chaînes de télévision et le moins que
l'on puisse dire c'est qu'elle va
susciter des réactions très
[Musique]
contrastées quand j'ai vu la vidéo de de
son papa euh ben en fait moi ça m'a fait
beaucoup de
peine donc en fait ça m'a fait pleurer
c'est du bidon ça sa vidéo ça veut rien
dire je la crois pas sa
[Musique]
vidéo bah parce que tout ce qu'il dit
c'est
rien je peux le faire par ce cinéma si
vous
voulez mais il y a une chose que
benénitez n'avait pas prévu en voulant
clamer son innocence
c'est que sa vidéo allait être le
déclencheur d'un énorme coup de théâtre
qui ne ferait que renforcer la thèse de
sa
culpabilité nous sommes à Nim à une
centaine de kilomètres des lieux du
drame ce même 5 août
2013 à 20h alors que la vidéo du
légionnaire tourne en boucle dans les
médias un homme reconnaît Francisco
Benitez
son visage lui est
familier il connaît parce qu'il a
sa belle sœur qui était la compagne de
ménitès dans les années
2004 cette
compagne s'appelait Simon et chose
incroyable cette femme qui a été la
maîtresse du légionnaire pendant un ans
a aussi disparu subitement c'était il y
a 9 ans en novembre 2004
étrange
coïncidence alors ce 5oût devant son
poste de télévision l'homme fait tout de
suite le rapprochement entre la
disparition de Simon de Olivera et celle
de Marie José et
d'Ison ce témoin prévient la police
judiciaire de NIM qui rouvre
immédiatement l'affaire sur la
disparition de Simon et ce que les
policiers vont apprendre dépasse
l'entendement lesqu découvre en effet
d'étranges similitudes
entre les disparitions d'Allison et de
sa mère et celle de Simone a commencé
par le profil des deux mères de famille
comme Marie José Simone et serveuse et
elle aussi vit seule avec ses quatre
enfants à chaque fois benitess semble
s'intéresser à ce type de femme à ce
type de profil de femme
euh divorcé un peu un peu perdu un peu
paumé un peu à la dérive
à l'époque de sa liaison avec Simon de
Olivera Francisco Benitez vit déjà avec
Marie José Alison elle a 10
ans cette relation extraconjugale durera
un peu moins d'un an jusqu'au 29
novembre 2004 date à laquelle Simon
disparaît
mystérieusement ça lui ressemble pas
d'autant plus que nous sommes au le fin
novembre fin novembre de l'année et que
c'est une une femme qui aime beaucoup
ses enfants et qui déjà a commencé les
préparatifs des fêtes de Noël alors
comment expliquer la disparition de
Simone de
Olivera plusieurs hypothèses se
profil est-ce qu'elle avait découvert
qu'il avait Marie José et sa fille qu'il
avait donc une double vie est-ce qu'elle
était par exemple enceinte et qu'elle
voulait le lui sa est-ce qu'il est-ce
qu'elle connaissait l'existence de Marie
José et que lui s'était engagé à trouver
une solution à leur histoire
sentimentale voilà trois hypothèses en
gros qui sont acceptable Francisco
Benitez le légionnaire sera entendu par
les gendarmes dans le cadre de cette
affaire depuis sa caserne de
saint-cistol et il dira ecement oui oui
j'ai entretenu une relation depuis
presque un an avec Simon Olivera ALV oui
effectivement nous avons décidé de
rompre elle a quitté son domicile après
envoy avoir envoyé un
message à Francisco benitz pour lui dire
pour lui annoncer son intention de
partir de disparaître et pour assoir ses
propos benitz va exhiber au gendarmes un
texto émanant de Simone où elle lui
signifiait la rupture un texto donc qui
innocenterait
benénitz exactement comme celui envoyé
par Marie Joo le jour de sa
disparition cette nouvelle similitude
troublante entre les deux affaires
pourrait signer le même mode opératoire
et ramène à une seule et même personne
Francisco Benitez qui avait le plus
intérêt à ce que Simon de Olivera
disparaissent
qui avait le plus intérêt à ce que
Simone d' Olivera n'allait pas n'aille
pas révéler son existence à la famille
de bénitess à sa femme à sa fille en
clair Simon la maîtresse avait-elle
l'intention de tout révéler à Marie José
l'épouse Francisco Benitez l'aurait-il
éliminé pour éviter qu'elle
parle mystère d'ailleurs à l'époque le
légionnaire n'est pas inquiété il
s'envole avec Marie José et Alison pour
Mayotte où il vient d'être
affecté le couple se mariera quelques
semaines plus
tard l'affaire Simon de Olivera aura en
tout cas montré une chose Francisco
Benitez est un homme
infidèle et les policiers vont très vite
s'apercevoir que le légionnaire
multipliait les conquêtes
en effet il y a une autre femme qui va
jouer un rôle déterminant dans cette
affaire elle s'appelle Maria Teresa elle
seu détient peut-être la clé de l'énigme
de la disparition d'Allison et de sa
mère en effet lors de leurs
investigations la PJ de perpignon
découvre que dans la nuit du 4 au 5 août
vers 1h du matin soit quelques heures
avant de se donner la mort le
légionnaire a passé un ultime appel
juste avant de passer à
l'acte de la mort de se donner la mort
il va appeler cette femme donc c'est pas
euh une Cassière de supermarché qu'il a
rencontré 10 minutes avant c'est
quelqu'un d'important dans sa
vie au bout du fil c'est Maria Teresa
elle a 39 ans elle est mariée mère de
famille et habite en Espagne à 1 heure
de
Perpignan cette femme est-elle la
maîtresse de benénitez les enquêteurs
veulent en savoir plus et la convoque le
8 août 2013 d'emblé elle conteste avoir
été la maîtresse de benénitèess elle
reconnaî qu'elle connaissait depuis le
mois d'avril qu'il y a eu une espèce de
relation
sentimentale amicale qui s'est qui
s'est organisé entre
eux il se voyaaient relativement peu en
revanche il communiquait beaucoup par
mail texto téléphone également c'est
tout ce que les enquêteurs obtiendront
de cette femme cette
femme n'a pas tout dit au service de
police parce que elle cherchait avant
tout à préserver peut-être sa vie de
couple et à préserver donc son mari et
ses
enfants pourtant Maria thesa sait des
choses d'ailleurs elle va les confier à
une journaliste
elle va faire des révélations qu'elle
n'avait pas fait à la police à savoir
qu'elle a passé la nuit du 19
juillet avec benénitess au domicile
familial le 19 juillet 2013 soit 4 jours
après la disparition d'Allison et de sa
mère Maria Teresa raconte qu'elle a
passé la nuit au domicile de Francisco
benénitez il vit à la Légion depuis un
moment puisquils sont en instance de
séparation
avec son
épouse il a en appartenant à laion mais
c'est au domicile familial que qu'il
amène sa
confidente étrange pourquoi Francisco
benénitez prend-il le risque d'inviter
Maria thesa chez lui alors que sa femme
et sa fille partis pour une petite
escapade peuvent revenir à tout
instant s'il a pris la décision de faire
venir sa maîtresse chez lui cette nuitl
une nuit tout entière c'est qu'il savait
pertinemment qu'elle ne risquait pas de
revenir devant la journaliste Maria
thesa va plus loin elle ajoute un détail
qui fait froid dans le dos cette nuit-là
elle aurait remarqué une très forte
odeur une odeur de
pourriture à l'époque elle pense qu'il
s'agit des poubelle de la
rue et c'est terriblement troublant
parce que le 19 on est à 4 jours de la
disparition des deux femmes et on peut
enfin on sait pas mais on peut imaginer
qu'il avait peut-être encore un cadavre
ou peut-être deux cadavres à l'intérieur
de
l'appartement ces nouveaux éléments
apportés par Maria Teresa semble
accabler un peu plus Francisco Benitez
et ce n'est pas
fini un autre témoignage va venir étayer
la thèse de l'assassinat d'Ison et de sa
mère c'est un autre légionnaire qui
confie au policiers qu'un jour il a dû
rendre service à bénitess un jour qui
est pareil situé quelques jours après la
disparition donc quelques jours après le
14 juillet où il l'a aidé à transporter
un congélateur de son domicile privé à
son domicile
caserne et une fois ce congélateur
installé à la caserne il l'a passé au
carchet à
l'intérieur la police judiciaire se rend
donc à la caserne et saisit le fameux
congélateur mais également le lave-linge
de l'appartement de fonction de
bénitè ils sont envoyés pour analyse
dans un laboratoire à Marseille qui
emploie une méthode de pointe dans la
recherche des traces de
sang la technique
moléculaire ça retrouve des tâches
beaucoup plus petite beaucoup plus
infime et même quand elles ont été
nettoyées au carcher à l'utre javel et
cetera les résultats ne se font pas
attendre 6h à peine après les
prélèvements la France entière est sous
le
[Musique]
choc dans le congélateur de Francisco
Benitez les experts relèvent des traces
ADN appartenant à
on a appris que c'était des traces de
sang ce sont des des traces de
sang l'examen du laveelinge sera
largement aussi
parlant des traces de sang d'adison sont
retrouvé dans le filtre et sur les
joints de la
machine on peut imaginer qu'en fait si
effectivement il y a des vêtements qui
ont été lavés dans cette dans ce
lavelinge qui portaient des traces de
sang trac d'ADN de Allison
Benitez désormais pour les proches
d'Allison les choses sont claires la
jeune candidate au titre de Miss
Roussillon a été tuée pire c'est très
probablement son père Francisco Benitez
qui est le meurtrier quand on voit qui
qui retrouve du
sang on se dit mais voilà à partir du
moment où on nous parle de sang
hein on attattend pas une bonne nouvelle
après par la suite he
après un mois et demi d'enquête les
policiers font un
bilan deux femmes ont disparu et ne
donnent plus aucun signe de
vie des traces de sang ont été
retrouvées au domicile du suspect dans
un congélateur et dans un
[Musique]
lav-elinge une maîtresse Maria Teresa ne
dit visiblement pas toute la vérité
et puis un suspect Francisco Benitez qui
se suicide sans laisser un mot derrière
lui pour sa femme et sa
[Musique]
fille le moins que l'on puisse dire
c'est que tous ces éléments semblent
convergé vers la culpabilité du
légionnaire reste maintenant pour les
enquêteurs à comprendre pourquoi ce père
de famille militaire bien noté par ses
supérieurs aurait commis
l'irréparable et voici le mobile qu'ils
imaginent celui d'un crime
[Musique]
passionnel d'abord Alison la fille de
Francisco Benitez a découvert que son
père trompait sa mère avec une
[Musique]
espagnole il m'avait dit ben moi mon
père je crois qu'il a une maîtresse et
je sur son téléphone j'ai vu qu'il enyé
des sa jeune fille et Alison aurait
aussitôt prévenu sa mère Marie
José et c'est là que lui a dit maman
papa une maîtresse en
Espagne parce que c'est aperçu au
portable qui avait des appels
d'Espagne cette découverte était même
devenue une source de conflit entre le
père et la fille Alisson il avait dit à
un moment
donné au lieu de t'occuper de il vudrait
mie que t'occuper de tes
[Musique]
maîtresses pour les policiers Marie José
femme bafouée trompé au moins à deux
reprises avec Maria thesa l'espagnole et
9 ans plus tôt avec Simone aurait-elle
menacé son
mari car selon certains témoignages la
femme du légionnaire le soupçonnait
d'avoir fait disparaître Simon autres
témoignages disent aussi que Marie José
benites était au courant de la Lison et
l'avait
découvert au moment de l'audition de
Francisco benitess suite à la
disparition de Simon à et peut-être
qu'elle était tout simplement sur le
point de dénoncer
bénitess parce qu'elle savait des choses
et qu'il a fallu la faire taire je m'en
rappelle elle m'a dit je vais faire
quelque chose de très compliqué à faire
et difficile à
dire quand je lui ai posé la question je
lui dit Marie qu'est-ce que tu veux dire
par là elle m'a dit je peux pas te le
dire pour le moment les enquêteurs
auraient alors le début d'un mobile
maintenant ils doivent établir le
scénario du double
[Musique]
meurtre le 14 juillet 2013 au matin au
domicile familial Francisco benénitez
aurait tué Marie José son épouse lors
d'une dispute peut-être au sujet de ses
infidélités et des circonstances qui
entourent la mort mystérieuse de Simon
de Olivera
les choses se seraient envenimé au point
de déclencher une violente altercation
qui aurait été fatale pour Marie
Jos seul dans la maison Francisco
Benitez aurait alors fait disparaître le
corps de sa
femme puis le légionnaire envoie un SMS
à sa fille souvenez-vous elle est au
restaurant avec ses amis à ce moment-là
d'ailleurs le comportement d'Allison
change du tout au tout son père
venait-il de lui annon que Marie José
avait quitté le domicile familial suite
à une
dispute ce 14 juillet 2013 à 14h
Francisco Benitez vient chercher sa
[Musique]
fille dans la voiture Alison aurait
tenté de joindre sa mère en vain son
téléphone ne répond
plus dès lors la jeune femme a peut-être
compris qu'il s'était passé quelque
chose de grave
acculé par sa fille Francisco Benitez
n'aurait donc plus d'autre choix que de
supprimer
Alison pour cacher son terrible
secret le 3 septembre 2013 une
information judiciaire contrix pour
assassinat est ouverte à
perpign
Francisco Benitez mort seulle une
autopsie pourrait en partie expliquer le
drame alors la justice va tout tenter
pour retrouver les corps d'Allison et de
Marie
José et pour se faire et bien ils vont
se servir une fois de plus de la
technique de la géolocalisation du
téléphone portable de
benitèess à la période de la
disparition grâce à la localisation de
son téléphone portable les enquêteurs
trace les déplacements de benénitz entre
le 14 et le 17 juillet 2013 soit dans
les 3 jours suivant la disparition des
deux
femmes et le militaire se serait rendu à
plusieurs reprises dans une zone précise
de la région à
porortlecat un espèce d'immense terrain
euh sur lequel un terrain sablonneux
euh extrêmement abandonné en tout cas un
terrain très discret où il aurait pu
avoir tout loisir d'enterrer les les
corps de sa femme et de sa
fille le 10 septembre la police et la
gendarmerie aidés d'une brigade
cinophile lance d'immense recherche sur
la fameuse zone de port Lecat à la
recherche des corps d'Allison et de sa
mère ça a duré quasiment 2 mois ils ont
fait des fouilles avec des chiens avec
des moyens
subaquatiques si in temp soit-elle les
fouilles ne donnent
rien les investigations sont alors
élargies à toute la région seulement la
tâche s'annonce difficile surtout si
Francisco benénitz et bel et bien le
coupable
benitz c'est un légionnaire il est
adjudant il a un parcours d'homme de
terrain un baroueur il a été au quatre
coins du globe partout où il y avait une
guerre ou en tout cas des événements il
s'y est frotté et s'il a décidé de se
débarrasser de ses corps et s'il a
décidé surtout qu'il ne fallait pas
qu'on les retrouve à mon avis on les
retrouvera
pas aujourd'hui l'enquête sur la
disparition d'adison et de sa mère est
au point mort aucune preuve for
ne permet d'affirmer avec certitude que
Francisco Benitez est coupable d'avoir
tué sa femme et sa
fille cependant parmi les proches de la
prétendante au titre de Miss Roussillon
la culpabilité du légionnaire fait débat
quand je repense moi à mes souvenirs que
j'ai de lui avec sa fille je peux pas
croire que c'est lui qui a fait ça on a
retrouvé de l'ADN l'ADN ça m pas les
enquêteurs vont quand même pas
il s'est passé quelque chose quand j'ai
appris le suicide du papa c'est que pour
moi Alison n'était déjà plus là parce
que je considère que n'importe quel papa
si sa fille a disparu jusqu'au bout il
la cherchera mais il mettra pas fin à
séjour 11 août 2013 il est
20h30 l'élection de Miss Roussillon
débute sur scène la fête a un goût amer
en fait sur les 11 candidates qui
défilent une manque à l'appel Alison
Benitez théoriquement chaque prétendante
porte un
numéro mais ce soir-là ce sont des
lettres qu'elles endossent car aucune
d'elles n'a souhaité hériter du chiffre
2 celui que justement Alison devait
porter ce numéro 2 on pouvait pas le lui
prendre c'était c'était à titré à
Alisson et personne d'autre pouvait le
porter sur les 12 candidates même si ce
jour-l on était 11 on pouvait pas faire
du d'être de la numéro 1 candidate au
numéro 11 c'était pas
possible le 11 août 2013 c'est
finalement Norma Julia 21 ans qui était
lu Miss
Rousillon mais ce soir-là la famille et
les proches d'Allison Benitez ne peuvent
s'empêcher d'imaginer que c'est elle qui
aurait dû être à sa place et porter le
célèbre diadème des
Miss
[Musique]